[Music]
[Doctor:] ...ask do we have any
guidelines for the future
[Narrator:] This man has acute myelogenous leukemia.
He has flown from his home in Denver
to the U.S. Public Health Service Hospital  in Baltimore,
for new treatment with drugs.
[Patient:] I didn't realize this but I was
interested to know
so that I could do some personal planning.
[Doctor:] Yes.
[Patient:] Along these lines..
[Doctor:] I think this is very important for
you to take care of your own,
make sure your house is in order.
[Patient:] Sure, umm I was wondering what
the possibilities of a remission
would be with the drugs which you have mentioned
and how long this remission would last.
[Doctor:] With our present experience, we are getting remissions at
somewhat over one-third, forty percent of patients.
It is true that when you do reach remission status
you are clinically and hematologically normal,
there's no evidence of leukemia whatsoever.
Now, our big problem is we are just stymied
and are unable to maintain the remission too long.
Exactly from case to case, to predict how long it will last,
I can't do.
We do have some patients that have been in remission well over a year,
a year and a half, two years.
[Patient:] That's a substantial time.
[Doctor:] But there are many many patients
who were only in remission one or two months.
But of course, let's say we do use daunomycin,
we do get a remission and in the event that
relapse does occur,
we can use cytosine arabinoside.
In fact, we have other drugs after that.
One of the benefits of being here at least,
is that there are always new things on the
horizon that are here
if a breakthrough does occur, you have a good
chance of participating
in that breakthrough here.
[Narrator:] In medical research, there is always
hope for a breakthrough.
Can science find a drug to cure cancer?
[A nurse wheels a patient on a gurney through
the hospital.]
[Narrator:] Cancer has been treated for some
time.
Many of the cancers which form solid tumors
can be treated with surgery.
If all the cancerous tissue is removed, the
patient is cured.
[Surgeons work on a patient in the operating room.]
[Surgeon:] Let's have another [?] please.
[Narrator:] The same is true of radiation
treatments.
Cure depends upon destruction of all the cancerous
tissue.
But sometimes the cancer spreads to other
parts of the body.
Leukemia, or cancer of the blood, is of course
all over the body.
In such cases the ideal therapy would be a
chemical
which could spread through the body and kill
every cancer cell.
[People are shown walking into the National Institutes of Health Clinical Center.]
[Narrator:] For more than a decade there has
been a national program
to find and test anti-cancer drugs, administered and supported
in great part by the National Cancer Institute at Bethesda, Maryland.
The search is worldwide.
There are ten million natural products that
might contain an anti-cancer compound.
Near Nairobi, botanists gather leaves and the bark of trees to process and test against cancer.
[Botanists gather plant material.]
[A man swims using a snorkel.]
[Narrator:] In the shallow waters of the Caribbean,
marine biologists collect invertebrates like
the west Indian starfish.
[Marine biologist lifts the starfish out of
the water.]
[Narrator:] As part of the nationwide cancer
chemotherapy program,
they process and test the starfish to find
out whether it might
contain drug materials effective against leukemias
and solid tumors.
The search goes on in North Carolina,
with the gathering of plants and grasses
by botanists with the United States Department
of Agriculture.
[The botanist digs plants out of the soil.]
[Narrator:] Any of these could contain a valuable
anti-cancer agent.
To test these materials for anti-cancer activity,
researchers might screen them in one thousand
animal tumors...
against one hundred different human cancers.
How can scientists determine what chemicals
are in these dried twigs?
[Scientist prepares twigs to be crushed and analyzed.]
[Narrator:] How can such chemicals be tested
safely in human beings with cancer?
The unknown material sent in from the field
is first processed and tested for anti-cancer
capability
in two so-called animal models:
laboratory mice, with a known leukemia, and
rats with a known tumor.
[Scientist injects animals.]
[Narrator:] These two types of cancer catch
almost all actives.
If the compound is an active, it will reduce
the tumor mass,
as compared with the tumor in a rat that got
no compound.
[The tumors are placed side by side to compare the effects of the two treatments.]
[Narrator:] But if the compound kills tumor cells in a rat,
it is likely to kill some normal cells too.
To measure these adverse effects,
researchers administer the compound to monkeys.
[A monkey is injected.]
[Narrator:] After a suitable period, they remove
a sample of the monkey's blood
and subject it to a series of tests that reveal
the effects of the unknown chemical on normal
blood cells.
For example, the coagulation time.
[Doctors use a stopwatch to monitor the coagulation
time of the monkey's blood.]
[Narrator:] Other tests show other effects
on the blood,
and on the kidney, the liver and spleen,
and particularly on the bone marrow
where red corpuscles and white blood cells
are manufactured.
Such tests indicate the chemicals' toxicity
and help define a safe dose for the test
in human beings.
If a compound shows anti-cancer activity,
other researchers try to determine what it
is composed of, by means of
column chromatography and many other tests.
The chemical compounds flowing down this column,
stratified in this way because of their unique
molecular properties,
may turn out to be potent anti-cancer agents.
More likely they will not.
Only about one agent in fifteen thousand tested
has proven effective.
Chemists also attempt to synthesize new anti-cancer agents.
This is a plastic model, enlarged thousands
of times,
of a molecule essential to the reproductive
process in all cells.
To produce one effective drug,
researchers over many months removed one of
the hydrogens
and put a fluorine in its place,
producing an antagonist that is absorbed by the cell
as if it were the real thing...
then destroys it.
In the last test,
a safe and effective dose for human beings
is determined by preclinical pharmacologists.
[Researchers in white lab coats enter a meeting
room.]
[Narrator:] The moment of truth in the long
search is the clinical trial.
Will the leaves and grasses from Nairobi,
or the compound synthesized in a laboratory,
make a drug to control cancer in human beings?
This is a regular staff conference in the
Clinical Center at Bethesda.
Case histories of patients on trial programs
are presented.
In this instance, the first patient on a new
drug.
Then the doctors discuss the implications
of their findings
for the nationwide research program.
[Muffled noise from doctors chatting in the
background.]
[Narrator:] A doctor wonders where the first
phase of drug study should be done.
[Clinical Doctor 1:] In other words, maybe
the phase one study
should be done on patients with diseases in which there is
no established, accepted therapy that would benefit
them.
[Clinical Doctor 2:] Suppose you get phase
one information, say on a solid tumor,
and you get some idea what the toxicity,
but you really, is that going to apply in
the face of an acute leukemia, CML
[?] and I, I think..
[Clinical Doctor 1:] Well, at least you would
have evaluated the drug
under uh, relatively clean conditions.
[Clinical Doctor 3:] Yeah but I think the
problem...
[Clinical Doctor 1:] Where it gets complicated
I think,
when it involves the marrow, the disease involves
the marrow.
[Narrator:] Much research is being done on
the size of the dose.
Large single doses kill cancer cells effectively,
but they also kill some normal cells, so doctors
must balance dosage
against adverse side effects.
[Clinical Doctor 2:] Chuck, we've had one patient who's been on eight hundred,
which is twice this dose.
[Chuck:] And what's happened to him?
[Clinical Doctor 4:] Uh, he tolerated the
single dose of eight hundred milligrams [?] quite well.
He left the hospital.
The second set of liver function tests are
going to be done this week.
Uh, but uh we haven't heard from him.
I venture he's doing quite well.
[Narrator:] Combinations of four drugs are
effective,
but it has been difficult to follow up certain
four-drug programs
with some of the new drugs, such as cytosine
arabinoside.
[Clinical Doctor 1:] I think this brings up
an important point
about where phase one studies should be done,
because we noted when we first started using
cytosine arabinoside,
it was after the four-drug combination, after
people relapsed,
and we saw a significant number of patients
with uh,
often quite severe lymphatic damage with cytosine
arabinoside.
And we were very concerned about it.
Other institutions were starting right off
with cytosine arabinoside, and you know,
and so I think it's probably for the same
reason.
The people we had had been in remission an
average of nine or ten months.
And uh, the time they got the cytosine arabinoside
they were just more sensitive to drugs.
Same thing applies to re-induction with the
four-drug combination.
We saw a higher degree of lymphatic dysfunction
in re-induction with the same drugs
than we did in primary induction
when the patient was first diagnosed.
[Muffled noise in the background; doctors
chatting again.]
[Narrator:] Some cancers adversely affect
the bone marrow,
where red corpuscles and white blood cells
are produced.
By studying a sample of the bone marrow,
doctors can follow the evolution of the disease
and the effects of different drug programs.
[Clinical Doctor 2:] What does the present
bone marrow show?
I mean, did we get our own marrow
or are we relying on the marrow from cytogenetics?
[Off-screen Doctor:] No, we have not obtained
the marrow yet.
[Female Doctor:] He hasn't had one yet here,
but he had [?] rods in the peripheral blood
so we're not in any doubt about the diagnosis.
[Off-screen Doctor:] But the percent blasts
are only five percent.
[Narrator:] To take a marrow sample, the doctor
carefully anesthetizes the local area,
then inserts the needle through the flesh
into the end of the bone.
[A needle is inserted into the bone of the
patient.]
[The needle is forced further down until it
reaches the bone marrow.]
[Narrator:] And on into the marrow.
A syringe withdraws a small sample of the
marrow.
This is placed on microscope slides, then
examined.
[The slides are prepared and placed under a microscope., which the scientist adjusts.]
[Narrator:] This marrow sample from a patient
with acute leukemia is hypercellular,
saturated with malignant cells.
At a larger magnification the malignant cells,
called blasts, show an unusually large nucleus.
After two courses of treatment with drugs,
a marrow sample might show fewer blasts
and increasing numbers of normal white cells,
a sign of improvement.
Later, in remission, when the disease is under
control,
there will be only five percent blasts.
But the peripheral blood, the blood that is
flowing through the body,
is also a good indicator of the state of the
patient's disease and the efficacy of treatment.
[Narrator:] A sample of the patient's blood
is diluted and placed on a counter.
The dials reveal the number of blood cells
in a measured sample.
A symptom of leukemia is an excessive number
of abnormal white blood cells,
ineffective against invading micro-organisms.
Cancer research needs many blood donors.
[A woman sits in a chair, having her blood drawn by a medical worker.]
[Narrator:] Leukemia, for example, sometimes
reduces the number of blood platelets,
the tiny cells that maintain the integrity
of blood vessel walls,
Bleeding may result.
But, platelets can be replaced by transfusion.
Whole blood is removed,
centrifuged to bring down the heavier red
cells,
and placed on an extractor that squeezes the platelet-rich plasma
off the top of the sample, for transfusion into
the patient--
in this case, the son of the donor.
Since both the drug and the cancer may affect
the body's ability
to resist invading micro-organisms,
many patients die of infection.
For protection, some patients are placed in
a plastic bubble
that completely surrounds them at all times.
Doctors conduct routine examinations
even though they are completely cut off from
the patient.
Only filtered air and aseptic materials enter
this sterile, private world.
Yet doctors can perform bone marrow and other
operations.
[Doctor extracts bone marrow from the quarantined
patient.]
[Narrator:] This laminar flow room now under
test at Bethesda
may someday replace the plastic bubble.
It will repel micro-organisms by continually
blowing
fresh, filtered air across the patient.
Doctors and visitors will enter and remain
downstream
If the experimental drug cannot control the
number of white blood cells,
doctors use the continuous-flow blood cell
separator,
shown at the M.D. Anderson Hospital and Tumor
Institute in Houston.
The machine draws whole blood from one arm,
pumps it through carefully sterilized tubes
to a weight-sensitive
buffer bag which controls the pump,
and sends it to a centrifuge which is similar
to a cream separator.
Because of the different densities of white
cells, red cells,
and other blood elements,
they separate at different points along the
radius of the disk.
Unwanted cells are shunted aside and the rest
returned to the patient.
[Chuck:] This is an important point...
[Narrator:] If a drug is successful against
one kind of cancer in phase one,
it is tested against other kinds.
Then it is sent for further tests to many
hospitals around the country.
[Clinical Doctor 2:] Does anyone know what the liver toxicity has been with the first end result?
Since that's been tried pretty extensively now in the midwest.
[Clinical Doctor 1:] There has not really
been much mention made of
liver toxicity in the patients that have been
evaluated
after therapy, so I would assume,
although I don't know directly, that we haven't
used the old drug here.
That there really isn't a significant amount
of liver toxicity
with that particular kind of thing.
[Narrator:] Always there are the questions
of scheduling.
Balancing dosage against toxicity.
[Clinical Doctor 1:] We ought to really be
careful about how we evaluate and look at toxicity...
[Clinical Doctor 2:] No
[Clinical Doctor 1:] in the circumstances
that occur so we don't do this all over again.
[Clinical Doctor 2:] I'll agree with you very
much on that.
The thing is, one of the reasons that we are
happy with this
type of schedule; that is, giving one dose,
and then waiting to see recovery,
is that it gives us time to back off and let
things uh,
let the toxicity abate,
and I think it's probably the safest way to
start out giving a drug.
[Narrator:] And finally the question of an
adequate trial for each drug.
[Clinical Doctor 3:] What would you consider
an adequate trial for this drug,
how much and how long?
[Clinical Doctor 1:] In this particular patient?
[Clinical Doctor 3:] Yes, how long?
[Clinical Doctor 1:] Well, I think that the,
I would think that
in this particular patient,
if the physicians in charge think it's due
to liver,
then I suspect...liver toxicity is due to
the drug...
then you can say well, we have this stuff
because of liver toxicity,
but my only question is I'm not so sure we
can attribute it all to the drug
and would feel that the risk involved in giving
him, say, a half-dose
would not be that great.
It would still allow us to see if this drug
is indeed going to be useful.
And we're hoping that uh, this drug would
be useful in this particular instance.
[Narrator:] In clinical research the doctor
is concerned
not just with a drug and an effective schedule
of administration,
but with a whole patient and his disease.
[Doctor:] You've given her daunomycin how long?
[Doctor 2:] She's gotten one dose.
[Doctor:] One dose.
[Doctor 2:] Exactly one week ago and she is
scheduled for her second dose today.
[Doctor:] Have you ever had any trouble with
your heart?
[Patient:] Not that I know of.
[Doctor:] Never had a murmur as a child?
[Doctor:] Have you found anything?
[Doctor 2:] Her cardiac status is completely
normal as far as we can tell.
[Narrator:] But the doctor always returns
to the key questions.
Which dosage has worked? Which schedule has
been most effective?
[Doctor 2:] A level of sixteen thousand or
twenty-five thousand,
but in terms of concentration, it's not too
different.
[Doctor:] She didn't respond at all to actinomycin?
[Doctor 2:] Ahhh, on one occasion her titer became completely negative,
that is zero, and subsequently came back up
again, though.
This was on actinomycin day.
[Doctor 2:] In the last few months she's received
three or four courses of methotrexate infusion
type and her titers have
gone down and back up, but her general course has remained essentially unchanged.
[Doctor 2:] In the light of the natural course of this disease
it's fair to say the methotrexate has been
somewhat effective.
[Doctor:] Did you ever decide in your mind
whether
she was really drug-resistant or just perhaps a dosage...schedule...
[Doctor 2:] I think it's difficult to say.
If we could give the methotrexate more often,
perhaps we might have a better effect.
[Doctor:] What's been the limiting factor...
[Doctor 2:] The limiting factor has been um,
toxicity
related primarily to the ulcerations in her mouth and uh,
which have been quite severe, although not complicated by infection so far.
[Doctor:] She had ulcerations anywhere else
with methotrexate?
[Doctor 2:] No, not that we know of.
[Patient:] A rash.
[Doctor 2:] She did have a rash on her skin,
which I couldn't say was clearly related to
methotrexate, but may have been.
She has not had it with each dose.
[Doctor 2:] She's tolerated therapy actually
quite well.
[Doctor:] Did you notice anything when you
got your first dose of daunomycin?
[Patient:] No, I was really surprised.
[Doctor:] Pleasantly surprised?
[Patient:] Yes, very much so.
[Doctor:] Well, it's going to be a long dosage
schedule.
[Patient:] Okay.
[Doctor:] We've had some good luck with it,
as Dr. Nigel mentioned.
[Scene switches to a different patient's room.]
[Doctor 1:] Good morning.
[Mr. Simpson:] Good morning.
[Doctor 1:] How are you doing today?
[Narrator:] The guiding principal in all good
clinical research
is concern for the patient.
[Doctor 2:] That's not a worry, we don't, we're not quite as relaxed as you are.
[Patient:] Boy, I'm not relaxed.
[Doctor 2:] How's the back doing today, and
the legs?
[Mr. Simpson:] My legs hurt.
[Doctor 2:] They do hurt.
[Mr. Simpson:] Down here yeah. My back don't
bother me, hasn't for a long time.
[Doctor 2:] I wonder if you could roll over
on your side,
and roll towards the window. We just want to feel your back.
[Patient turns toward the window as instructed and doctor places his hand on the man's back.]
[Doctor 2:] I want you to tell me, Mr. Simpson if this uh,
when and if this hurts you at all.
That tender?
[Mr. Simpson:] No, not yet.
[Doctor 2:] That tender?
[Mr. Simpson:] Nope.
[Mr. Simpson:] That's a little bit.
[Doctor 2:] How 'bout over here?
[Mr. Simpson:] Nope.
[Doctor 2:] Over here?
[Mr. Simpson:] No.
[Doctor 2:] Right here?
[Mr. Simpson:] Well, I believe that's a little
bit right there.
[Doctor 2:] Here?
[Mr. Simpson:] Nope.
[Mr. Simpson:] No...a little bit right there. That's it at the end of your finger.
Right there.
[Doctor 2:] A lot or a little bit?
[Mr. Simpson:] No, just a little.
[Doctor 3:] I wonder if the [?] would reproduce any of the pain down the leg.
Well, Tom, we finally got the results on the x-rays.
[Mr. Simpson:] And what'd you get?
[Doctor 3:] And there does seem to be something that
may well be causing the pain down
the leg, but it's in this area.
Uh, we're going to talk with the radiotherapy
people today
and see if they can help us on it.
We'll let your know later on today on that.
[Mr. Simpson:] You'll let me know today.
[Doctor 3:] I think so, it'll depend on when
they will be able to get to see you.
Your next course of chemotherapy starts next
week.
[Mr. Simpson:] Next week?
[Doctor 3:] Yeah, Tuesday..
[Doctors 1 and 3:] Monday or Tuesday
[Doctor 3:] Depending on what your blood count
shows.
They think they can help you if they combine
the two.
[Mr. Simpson:] Okay.
[Doctor 3:] Okay so maybe that's, that's what's
doing it.
[Mr. Simpson:] You think so?
[Doctor 3:] Yeah, I think.
[Doctor 2:] Pretty good chance, uh-huh.
[Mr. Simpson:] I think that sounds right.
[Doctor 2:] Well everything else, you know,
has improved.
Lump has gone down, chest is better and so
forth.
[Doctor 2:] So if we can get this pain under
control I think uh,
everything should be a lot better, Mr. Simpson.
[Mr. Simpson:] Okay.
[Doctor 2:] So that's what we're shooting
for.
[Mr. Simpson:] All right.
[Doctor 2:] Okay.
[Narrator:] Where has the National Cancer
Institute program led?
In advanced forms of Hodgkin's disease,
a four-drug treatment produced complete remissions,
or temporary disappearance of all evidence of cancer in twice as many patients
as ordinarily achieved remission with single
drugs.
A group of thirty-five children with acute
leukemia were treated
intermittedly with massive doses of four drugs.
The median survival of these children was
three years
compared with a three-month survival of leukemic
children
twenty years ago.
The story of cancer drug research will continue
next week
in part two, "The Battle in the Cell."
[Music]
[Narrator:] For further information on Cancer chemotherapy, write for a free booklet,
Drugs versus Cancer, available from the Research Information Branch,
National Cancer Institute, Bethesda, Maryland.
[Music]
[Narrator:] These are normal human cells from prostatic tissue
living in a laboratory dish.
They were filmed through a microscope
that magnifies them two-hundred seventy times.
These are the same kind of human cells from
prostatic tissue,
grown and filmed in the same way,
but they are cancer cells.
The cells, normal and cancer, differ in ways
not yet fully understood.
It is the task of the cancer chemotherapist,
the scientist who hopes to control cancer
through the use of drugs,
to exploit those differences so that a drug can kill all of these cells,
without killing more than a few of these
in the same human being.
[Narrator:] Cancer has been treated successfully for some time
by surgery in which the malignant tissue is removed.
And by radiation in which it is destroyed
by cobalt and x-rays.
But sometimes cancer spreads to other parts of the body
even as the local area is being treated successfully.
In such cases, new hope may be offered by chemotherapy, the use of drugs.
[Doctor:] What treatments have you had? I know you had surgery; did you ever have x-ray therapy?
[Patient:] Um-hmm
[Doctor:] When was that?
[Patient:] Sixty-three I think. Couldn't say
for sure.
[Doctor:] And that was for a local recurrence
of your disease, I think.
[Patient:] Yes.
And then, did that hold it under control for a little while?
[Patient:] Yes, it did.
[Doctor:] And then what happened?
[Patient:] Well then, it started all over
again.
[Doctor:] Have you ever received any other
therapy?
Uhh, very often patients with breast cancer
get estrogen therapy, corticosteroids, cortisone.
[Patient:] The only thing I had was those
pills.
And what are those, I can't pronounce..
[Doctor:] Diethyl silbesterol, that's it.
[Doctor:] These are, are pills, this is hormones
that very often control cancer, breast cancer.
Did this help?
[Patient:] Yes, when I was taking two or three it helped make it better.
Then I had to stop because I had started my period.
[Doctor:] Basically, the problem with your disease is that
you did have localized disease and you received surgery
and then for a local recurrence, radiotherapy,
and I think now the problem is that the disease
is just too far out,
too widespread to be controlled
by any of these local means.
[Doctor:] Where did Dr. Hunter tell you that
you had disease?
[Patient:] My breast.
[Doctor:] Eventually what happens in cancer
is that we do have to use drugs.
[Patient:] Mhmm.
[Doctor:] Even after local therapy and after
hormonal therapy.
You did have the hormonal therapy, and the disease has progressed to
the point where your doctor did feel that
you should go to a center
that is more concerned, that has more experience
in drug treatment.
[Patient:] Right.
[Doctor:] Were you happy about going or were
you,
how did this strike you when you discussed
this with him?
[Patient:] Well, it kind of shocked me a little bit.
Then I made up my mind I would, he, he advised
me it was the best thing for me to do.
He said that if I could get in here I would be very lucky, so I told him I would.
[Narrator:] For more than a decade, the National Cancer Institute
has guided and supported a large national program of cancer chemotherapy.
Scientists are studying the whole patient,
the effects of many kinds of drugs on the
course of his disease,
and on the inner workings of cancer cells.
A cell is visible to the human eye only through
a microscope.
Nevertheless, it is the building block of
which all tissue is made.
When new tissue is needed the cell divides, each so-called mother
producing two daughters exactly like
the mother.
Each daughter produces two more daughters,
also the same.
When no more tissue is needed, the doubling
stops,
halted by an unknown biological signal.
The cancer cell and all its daughter cells
do not receive
or do not obey the signal.
They keep multiplying far beyond what the
body can tolerate.
This relentless growth of nonfunctional cells
can lead to illness and death.
The experimental evidence of this is startling.
Blood is withdrawn from the abdomen of a mouse
with leukemia.
[Scientist uses a syringe to to withdraw blood from the mouse's body.]
[Narrator:] It is diluted.
And the cells are counted under a microscope.
They are diluted and counted again,
until any given drop is likely to contain
only one or two leukemic cells.
With this instrument, called a micro-manipulator,
scientists at Southern Research Institute in Birmingham
today can isolate a single living leukemic
cell.
[The scientist assembles his micro-manipulator.]
[Narrator:] Using a hair-like tube, the technician places several drops
of the diluted material on a glass slide.
The slide is turned over so the drops are hanging
from the lower surface, and is placed under a microscope.
The technician locates a single drop.
He carefully moves a pipette, a delicate glass
tube, up under the slide.
And with hydraulically-operated controls that
scale down his movements,
he inserts it into the droplet...
and withdraws the leukemic cell.
The cell is transferred to a hypodermic syringe.
A single cancer cell.
It is injected into a normal, healthy mouse.
[A researcher holds a mouse in her hand and injects the cancer cell, then places the mouse in a cage.]
[Narrator:] Within eight days, there is a
noticeable abdominal swelling,
evidence of the growth of leukemic cells.
The cancer cells continue to increase, each
mother producing two daughters.
Each daughter producing two more daughters.
Until, after ten days the swelling in the
abdomen is pronounced.
By the nineteenth day, the single cancer cell will have proliferated
to more than one billion cells.
Enough to kill the animal.
But certain chemicals can stop this cancerous
growth.
In this laboratory culture, we see mouse leukemia cells dividing,
with cleavage as shown in the center of the screen,
completed after the usual length of time.
But when a drug is added,
the reproductive cycle of the cells is violentlydisrupted.
The cell in the center of the culture stays
at metaphase,
an intermediate stage in the division process,
an unusually long time.
Cleavage is irregular.
Daughter cells are of unusual size and do not survive very long.
Human cancer cells are also affected by drugs.
These cancer cells in a laboratory dish are dividing in the usual way,
as shown at far right.
If an alkaloid from the periwinkle plant is added,
cells proceed to the second phase of the cycle,
as seen in the rounded cells,
but cannot go beyond this phase.
Mother cells cannot produce daughters,
stopping the relentless reproduction
that characterizes the growth of cancer cells.
But it has been found that a given dose of
a given anti-cancer drug
destroys only a certain percentage of the
cells in a living animal.
Regardless of the absolute number of cancer cells,
the percentage destroyed by the same size dose will
always be the same.
Suppose a given type of cancer cell doubles
approximately every twelve hours.
Once every twenty-four hours we administer
a drug
which kills sixty percent of the cancer cells
present.
Again, the remaining cancer cells double.
And again, we kill sixty percent.
We have slowed them down,
but they are increasing faster than we are
killing them,
and they will eventually increase in mass
or number
to the point where they kill the animal.
We can increase the doses
so that we are killing the cancer cells faster
than they can multiply.
But anti-cancer agents also affect normal
cells.
If the dose is too large,
and if too many normal cells are killed while
we are destroying the cancer cells
the animal may sicken and die.
Is it possible to kill large numbers of cancer
cells with drugs
without killing too many normal cells?
[Narrator:] These normal mice are injected
with an anti-cancer drug called cyclophosphamide.
Twenty-four hours later the femur, or upper
leg bone of the mouse, is removed,
the ends clipped,
[The scientist uses a tiny instrument to clips the ends of the mouse's femur bone.]
[Narrator:] and the bone marrow, the site
of blood-forming stem cells,
is washed out and diluted in a laboratory
solution.
[The described procedure is shown.]
[Narrator:] To find out how the drug has affected
the marrow and its ability to produce cells,
the technician injects the diluted marrow
into a mouse
whose stem cells have been destroyed.
Ten days later, after the injected marrow
cells
have had a chance to multiply,
the animal's spleen is removed and fixed in
Bouin solution.
[The mouse's spleen is dropped into a test
tube filled with the solution.]
[Narrator:] Marrow cells form nodules on the spleen.
The number of nodules, in this case a dozen or so,
indicates the number of cells surviving,
a measure of the effects of the original anti-cancer agent on the normal cell.
But what does the agent do to cancer cells?
A lymphoma-bearing mouse is injected
and twenty-four hours later its bone marrow is removed.
Again following the same procedure used with the normal mouse,
the marrow is diluted and injected into the tail of a mouse,
which will serve as a kind of incubator
or culture dish for the marrow cells.
Eight days later the spleen of the cancer
mouse is removed.
Again the nodules are counted,
an indication this time of the rate of survival
of cancer cells after drug treatment.
To get good data, sixty-six such experiments
were conducted
at the Ontario Cancer Institute,
each one involving more than one hundred mice.
When the results were plotted,
the curve showing the percent survival of normal cells
as against increasing drug dosage, looked like this.
[Man draws curve on paper indicating relationship
between dosage and cells killed.]
The curve indicating percent survival of cancer cells
with increased drug dosage looked like this.
There is no question that some drugs kill
many more cancer cells
than normal cells in the same living organism.
And that kill-ratios vary with dosage.
So, dose amount, as well as timing, is important in the battle in the cell.
But can we further improve this ratio?
The ratio of cancer cell killed to normal
cell killed.
Just within the past couple of years,
a new approach to this problem has been developed,
based upon close observation of the life cycle
of the cell.
In addition to the phase during which the
cell divides,
there are several other cycle phases.
Generally, cells appear to rest in one phase,
synthesize genetic material in another,
rest again, then divide.
[A graphic illustrates as narrator describes the process.]
But timing is crucial.
How can we find the length of each phase in
the life cycle of a cancer cell?
At Southern Research Institute,
researchers use a radioactive material that
is absorbed into cancer cells
during the S phase.
[Scientists move about in the lab, preparing to run a test on the lab mice.]
They inject it into laboratory mice
with the solid tumor designated sarcoma 180,
let the tumor grow,
then remove it.
In this tumor, how many cells have taken up
the radioactive material?
How many have passed through the S phase and
on into mitosis, or cell division?
[The scientist is shown cutting a tumor in a petri dish into small pieces.]
After mincing the tumor,
the technician suspends it in a measured amount
of saline solution
and carefully breaks down the tumor tissue
in a laboratory homogenizer.
[A whirring sound is heard as the described process is shown.]
Then the technician strains the mixture
to remove large clumps of tissue,
and places the liquid containing radioactive
cancer cells
into a centrifruge.
[The centrifruge begins spinning.]
Later, the packed cells are treated in other ways
and are placed on glass slides, each carefully marked
for future identification.
[Carrying the cell sample slides, a scientist approaches and opens a lab door marked "Warning."]
[Narrator:] To find out how many cells are
radioactive,
and thus have passed through the S phase,
the slide is converted into a kind of photographic
plate.
It is coated with emulsion and left in a dark
room for six weeks.
[The described process is shown.]
To count the cells that have absorbed the
radioactive material,
the researcher not only examines all portions
of the slide under a microscope,
but also studies it on closed-circuit television.
Cells containing radioactive material are identified
by the dark spots on the emulsion.
On this slide, over three thousand cells were
studied and counted.
From this experiment,
the researchers determined that the life cycle
of the sarcoma 180 cell
is about thirteen and a half hours,
and that the S phase lasts almost eight hours,
important data in determining the best time
to administer drugs that kill during the S
phase.
Of the thousands of drugs tested, some apparently
kill only during the S phase of the life cycle.
Yet their kill ratio is good.
Of the thousands tested, some were found to
kill throughout the life cycle
and they also can give good cancer-cell to
normal-cell kill ratios.
But when these different kinds of drugs are
combined,
they can give much better kill ratios.
Much experimentation involves drug schedules.
Experimenters at Southern Research Institute
have developed ways to administer drugs steadily,
over long periods of time, to mice with different kinds of cancer.
A tube is inserted intraperitoneally
and the mouse is allowed to run into his small
chamber along with
a dozen or so of his cousins.
The experimental drug is drawn into a special
syringe.
[The described process is shown.]
And the syringe is mounted on a rack,
one syringe for each mouse.
Other syringes are filled with harmless saline
solution
for administration to a group of control mice.
They will be watched to see whether the apparatus,
rather than the drug,
affects them in any way.
Now each syringe is adjusted precisely
to ensure administration of a carefully measured
amount of drug.
[The described process is shown.]
The mice in their stalls are given a final
check,
a timer is started,
and the drug is fed through the tubes at a constant rate.
In this apparatus, the drug can be made eventually
to hit every cell
in a cancer mass,
no matter when or how long it is susceptible
to the drug.
But scientists thought it might be better
to treat the animal
with a single, stronger dose,
followed by other doses at a later time,
perhaps giving the normal cells more time
to recover
from drug damage before they are treated again.
Not long ago, Southern Research Institute
tested cytosine arabinoside
in a batch of mice with leukemia.
[A researcher makes notes on a pad of paper.]
In the first experiment,
they gave a measured dose of drug to hundreds
of animals,
once each day for a period
of fifteen days.
Some mice were used as controls; they got no drug.
At the end of the experiment,
the control mice died,
as predicted on the basis of the growing knowledge
of cell kinetics.
The experimental mice, those that got the drug,  lived much longer, although all eventually died.
When the results were averaged out, it was
determined that
the daily dosage had increased the lifespan of the
experimental mice substantially, although none were cured.
But, by simply changing the timing of the
administration,
the scientists got dramatically different
results.
They used the same kind of mice,
mice which have been inbred for generations
to enhance their similarity for laboratory purposes.
And the same drug, cytosine arabinoside,
and essentially the same size dose.
But instead of administering the drug once
a day,
they administered it every three hours around
the clock,
at four-day intervals.
Control mice again got no drug,
and again they died according to estimates
based on cell kinetics.
The experimental mice, those that got the
drug on the new schedule,
continued to live happily.
Some laboratory animals can be cured of cancer,
but human beings are a far cry from laboratory
animals.
Can drugs be found or designed that will destroy
the billions of cancer cells
that sometimes spread through human beings?
[A person enters a number using a rotary dialpad
on a large computer.]
A computer program developed at the National
Cancer Institute may help find the answer.
Into the computer are fed assumptions
about the generation time of a given cancer cell,
the duration of the S phase,
and the fractional cell kill of a given drug.
In seconds, the computer can reveal, among
other things,
the number of cells remaining at the end of
the dose period.
With such information, drug programs can be
tailored for individual patients.
Other progress is being made.
The animal model for testing drug activity
against cancer
is giving good biological information
that has a direct bearing on the disease in
man.
Although enormous problems remain,
there is hope that continued research
will lead to even greater life expectancy
for even more patients.
[Music]
[Narrator:]  For further information on Cancer chemotherapy, write for a free booklet,
Drugs versus Cancer, available from the Research Information Branch,
National Cancer Institute, Bethesda, Maryland.